[Music]
good
but gamers it's raining
i heard thunder before that's why it
stopped because there's a thing i really
want to try out with the trident i don't
know if i'm going to get trolled
oh okay it is thunder but if i start moo
cow
moo cow don't look at me like that i'm
doing a thing dj cow
yeah look away i don't know if this will
work
[Music]
don't look at me
i care bird was back by the way
to just get murdered again i had to
revert to an old save file
[Music]
don't don't look at me like that you're
fine
i'm out of here i don't need this i
don't need this sort of abuse
dj cow is like a father to me how could
you do this
[Music]
okay dj moo moo cow
how can you lie to me how could they do
this man this should be illegal
shoot the cow with the trident felix
it'll be really cool
it'll be really cool philly i was so
excited i was going to show you guys
look
i have two i mean two involuntarily
placed
opportunity of employment people i
haven't traded with them actually i
should probably should start doing that
yeah they're baby dying it's whatever
okay
so yeah as you can see they uh they're
doing a pretty good job
give me your money oh he wants pumpkin
well i have plenty of those
god damn boy
these two are making me rich god damn 38
emeralds
sven we're gonna be rich my melon farm
is so good
where did you come from
[Laughter]
no one escapes did you guys know you you
take melon slices and place them all
together
not cactus come on
what is this
keep guarding them sven make sure they
do their job
god damn i'm rich why is farming the
most
lucrative business of minecraft you know
if it's bad for me to bring in
people to work for me
involuntarily then why do they make it
so
good in the game
because my god
i'm rich what are they doing they're
freaky making in front of sven
hey not in front of sven stop
stop it press the button press the
button
quick don't look sven
oh that was close one
hey i don't pay you guys to make babies
seriously my melon farm is like the best
stop stop freaking less more farming all
right well let me show you guys uh
some of the other stuff i've been
working on i spent a lot of time
on my uh my frick chamber
i'm actually really excited about it i
have a lot of stuff to do today actually
uh
getting so distracted here too much
money too much riches
fame money and a fat bank account so i
want to
store all their money in front of them
so that they can see
where all their hard work goes to to me
hopefully i get to just demonstrate my
new
system i watched a few tutorials online
thank you very much
minecraft nerds uh so yeah i decorate it
a little differently
as you can see it's a bit more efficient
now to update and stuff like that and it
looks
i think it looks cool yeah yeah it looks
yeah it looks cool cool thanks
thanks guys so uh hey
i haven't shown my favorite bit which is
the fact that look this guy sells me
sharpness five and i'm like
okay that's freaking awesome this guy
sells me sharpness 3
and nothing else and i'm like well
you're useless so i have
this new uh system which is called
commit not villager anymore system so
you just press this button
and lava pours down from the ceiling and
bam bing bong
villager is gone and i can just place a
new villager
with my new railroad system that i have
implemented
oh actually i have a lot of new systems
you guys are gonna like this okay so
this is the feeding system right where
food food drops down from the ceiling
so which makes them go oh epic
now let's make bebe can't sleep right
now have to make pepe
the problem with this system is that
sooner or later it runs out of food i
gotta go up there and
refill it so one of the commenters left
a really nice
suggestion where uh i know i don't only
just have sl
i mean i don't only just have people
working for me involuntarily
to fee to make pepe i also have people
working
to feed the the feeder
so this guy feeds with the carrots so
this is assistant with a drop down but
then
it's also connected to the the automatic
farm
it feeds into the dropper whatever he
puts so that i don't have to refill it
basically
it's pretty awesome it's pretty cool
right so now
i'm going to feed them a little bit more
and hope that a new baby comes up
because i want to show you the railroad
system as well actually while we do that
there's another redstone thing i really
want to build where's your labrita
all right hey aaa labrita's in timeout
but you can come out now
you can come out now every time sorry i
got angry i lost
dj no stop how do they keep getting in
here
i hate you so much
how it's fenced up
oh my god i'm so sorry
hey man i'm so sorry i
i loved him too he sold me really good
prices
okay there is something i actually
really really really really really want
to do
because you guys have told me that as
beautiful as ikea tower is
you can make it even beautifuler by
adding a glass
stained what am i saying by adding a
glass stained
glass glass stain color stained glass
how do i do it damn
that's cool
[Music]
but i feel like yellow could be cool as
well
hmm oh my god yellow does look cool as
what color do you prefer yellow or blue
yellow okay
[Music]
don't think so
oh yeah you guys told me to put loyalty
too on or three
uh i could only get two on my trident
sven
what do you think yellow or blue you
want blue
okay but what if maybe we could somehow
have both oh my god that's genius let's
add both
i've been doing so much redstone i'm
like this is going to be so easy
so what we need to do is we make
one sticky piston i think i think we can
just keep all the wiring
on top of this like a floor above
maybe let's see if i
how you remember a clock i mean i know
how to how to build a bad clock
maybe i'll just do my bad clock now we
just need to place
this on top question mark
wait it mixes the colors
no
stop
that looks terrible so i need to ah this
is okay this is more complicated
than i thought
all right felix
you can totally be a big brain so what i
would do
what my brake brain is telling me
to make my clock my own clock which is
everyone keeps saying it's garbage
i don't care it's work okay
we start the pulse and then we extend
the pulse
okay and then we do the same on this
side
it's kind of a delay in between isn't it
i don't like that okay all right we do
it quicker
[Music]
why is there a delay
yeah this is gonna break what the
problem
i don't want the white one
no stop playing the actual game
trying to figure out spending hours
trying to figure out
why your redstone doesn't work i
oh my god i did it i'm such an idiot
i i use sticky pistons clearly
i just had to use regular piston and
that was all there was to it
i was like why'd not work oh because i'm
an idiot
there she is my god so beautiful
it took me half an hour longer because
i'm idiot but
man ikea towers so beautiful
[Music]
look is crying oh my god just realized
his eyes are dumb no
rip oh yeah everyone keep pointing out
the
the meeple is molding i don't know what
to do about it
what is this curse of vanishing
what where did he go how are you guys
doing you're sleeping all right you're
sleeping nice
everyone having a good time all right
i need to i need you to demonstrate
something maybe i need to make it like a
piss
get it maybe i need to make a piston or
something to push them now
this is not the way i never tried this
so he's in the hole ladies and gentlemen
so now we should be able to by hitting
this lever
get him up there i got i hope this works
it didn't work
the redstone i connected oh there we go
yeah i think we almost got it hold on
one second
okay oh god it's not a creeper
damn i love the trident okay all right
let's do this
go go
and it's success look it's a fisherman
that's awesome too bad we already have
one of those
all right that's enough
[Music]
it's time for me and sven to hang hand
out
on new epic adventure let's go sven oh
yeah i need to find
uh jorgen there's one part of
or well there's a couple parts but one
part in particular that i have never
discovered in minecraft
which is the the forest kind of area
like
the mountain type yo again
oh jurgen smergen there he is hello oh
you made new friend that's so nice
you've been here for a long time
let's go gamers
i think it's this way it is kind of
awkward since i don't have a house but
i was hoping we could gather materials
while we're away as well
all right see you later
uchiba
i am so epically anime oh my god they've
taken over
guys that's my fishing spine nothing in
this game works the way i want it
i'll never listen to you guys tips again
from now on this game is between me and
my boy
so i think there's a spruce area next to
the
to the jungle but i'm not entirely sure
we'll see classic adventure sven you're
again
this is what minecraft is all about what
are we gonna find
new epic friends that'd be great because
with the rate that i lose them if the
rate that i lose friends becomes greater
than gaming
then i'll have no friends oh we gotta
jump the water
nailed it oh my god black jurgen
meet black jurgen girlfriend can i make
them go sexy
oh of course he disappears some things
never change
i don't have wheat sorry sorry again not
today
oh my god it's raining that means i can
do this
nope oh my god it's not coming back
uh oh it's there oh it's coming back
whoa i thought i had respiration
oh my god it's raining don't worry again
i built you a little roof here we're
going to be right back
you'll be fine this van is like i don't
want to
i don't want to go i mean i have a
portal to this place but why use portal
when you can just bring your pets
isn't that right fade
oh there it is perfect this is like when
americans discovered america for the
first time
oh my gosh look at this
ow get him sven
you're in the boat you're not helping
watch this oh yeah
oh oh you see that's man
sure ah what
it hurt me sven help dangerous berries
ah
stay away from those men i don't ah
get him sven oh god stay back sven
please we're not here just for the
sprucing
cool it went through him get him sven
good job sven all right we'll set up
camp here
you hurt my boy you die a thousand times
my child good night gamer
ah how's it still raining
never mind
okay let's go deeper but let's be
careful sven
we don't know what to expect in this
place
danger could lurk in any corner
oh there they are we're heading for the
snowy mountains man
oh my god look at that scent quiet
yes oh my god yes okay
careful spent no
we're gonna abduct the child so what do
you can do
the way to tame foxes
sven please be quiet the way to tame
foxes is to steal the children while
they're sleeping
we should be fine can i do this does
that wake them up
okay okay we gotta go closer
oh frick oh my god they're so cute
got one
hey i'll take both of them they're mine
now
say bye to your mom i'm your new mom now
don't worry about it this is banked oh
okay
bang the new yeah very epic so once they
grow
up i think uh they'll love sven they
just need to forget about their mom all
right i'm your mom
call me mama
oh god oh god
i'll protect you at all cars oh my god
they're jumping they're crazy
where you going wow
that's awesome hey look they made the
new hey
stop stop no don't hurt
[Laughter]
okay fine kill it kill him
i'll i'll block him for you here you go
yeah incredible job
oh i keep sitting his mouth that's so
cute
as long as i don't take my trident sven
is like i can't look at this
all right to the mountains let's go
gamers
this is awesome
god i love the trident it's so epic like
i think they like me already banged okay
damn look at that that's so cool
[Music]
you never know what you're finding
minecraft
you never know what you're fine we lost
orca
oh god no okay okay oh god
stop harassing the chickens orchid
love the loan oh what are they doing ew
ew
[Music]
what the frick is wrong with you you
better not hurt people
people completely innocent i think i
think you can feed them berries no
that's definitely not it
and he took my leash give me back my
leash
oh my god no
how could you do don't no i don't want
to hurt them
oh yeah okay don't
don't don't don't oh i'm sorry
oh god no no
[Music]
why i could have given them a bone i
could have tamed them
damn that hurts is that cat i thought i
heard a cat
it's a kitty cat i only have cooked fish
dang it
don't look at me thanks you better
behave you saw what happened to your
brother
oh my god it is a village oh it's right
here
[Music]
that's so cozy look at that i like this
maybe i'll build my house like this
i should probably gather materials
hopefully they don't mind
[Music]
look at this yeah i like this a lot
what is this campfire oh
oh hey buddy what are you doing in here
you need help coming out there you go
you're welcome
you're free this is so cool i love this
area
more people hello people all right cool
miss me nice to meet you too
i'm from sweden as well this is more
like we're going to
oh it's getting dark oh this is perfect
we can set up camp here
you mind if i sleep here with my little
sheep
this is perfect all right
[Music]
all right we still haven't gone to the
mountains
whoa oh my god he's gray
what why
hey hey stop
god bank you're such a little nutions
all right do they have money no poor
all right we gotta climb that mountain
boys
i'd be lying if i said it's gonna be
easy that is so cool
i want to do this dude i'm getting yeah
this is great
i'm gary i'm getting inspo for my house
here
aren't you guys getting cozy vibes from
this
maybe we should move to the snow area
[Music]
whoa that looks like one of those sock
puppet hands
[Music]
that's awesome
violent ones baby
that's so awesome oh my god his head is
massive look at him
look at this little thing it's so cute
i'm taking you with me
you're coming with me hello hey hey why
are they following me
stop i only want your child stop
this is so cool okay so wait
new recipe we got snow baby
yeah oh my god we can make a snowman
oh my god the tiny one is the cutest can
you make them stay tiny forever
sorry sorry it wasn't me i swear hey
don't look at me don't look at me like
that it wasn't me i swear
look
back up so how do you build a snowman
you make block of snow
and then a carrot would make sense right
or is it a pump
i keep forgetting to add minecraft
dude look how pretty this game is
seriously
oh my god can i have one second
protect banked at all cost
and i lost him
oh god there he is
oh god he's all lost and lonely he
doesn't know where his mommy is don't
worry i'm your mama
i'm your mama i'm your mom it's very
realistic i'm your mom
he's sleeping that's so cute
eat become strong
oh he's snoring
hey good morning gamer
there's one last thing hey hey
oh oh perfect perfect perfect don't hurt
hey hey good hey eat
damn it ah
i'll protect you no matter what you
gotta stay in the
it's hole only way sven you like this
is when you like this
yes okay that was easier than i thought
okay now
look at that it's so cute
sven has a girlfriend
look at that what's your name miss sven
okay
cool what a creative name
so are you guys gonna you know what i
have a chamber back home that's perfect
for you guys
did i lose him again
he's so precious he keeps sleeping
what's the female version of sven there
there is none
it's sven it's his boyfriend sven okay
don't ask questions
sven and his boyfriend sven stop
sleeping my god
okay damn
i'll take a bonus i was just about to
head back
maybe we can uh ride the ship gamers
oh he grew up i think he likes me
jurgen is gonna freak out when he sees
us
jerk is gonna flip his mind when he sees
sven has a girlfriend
or boyfriend there he is
that's my boy
how was it buddy oh look at them they're
two like two peas in the pie
like two dogs in the boat whole gang is
back home baby
meat banked let's do a quick sleep
oh my god he sleeps with me she sleeps
with me
that's so cute i guess you really missed
me huh
it doesn't care oh no he ate the leash
here take this oh he changes okay cool
i'm about to do the corniest thing i've
ever done on this channel
can i not put a leash on the turtle damn
it
why not
okay oh yeah
everyone is gonna be there
to witness make sure we have banked yes
and then of course this one's bf
there it is oh look how cute they are oh
my gosh i almost forgot
okay is everyone here everyone's here
we have gathered here today
for sven and sven's boyfriend
to unite as husband and husband
in minecraft you may now kiss your
husband
[Music]
look at him his face is so big
oh my god yes
oh look how cute they are
[Music]
oh he's so cute
for once a happy episode except
of course dj cal but you know things
happen
all right that's it for me for today i
hope you guys enjoyed this episode smash
like if you did
protect sven merch at all cost out now
check it out support the channel and the
series see you guys next time
bye bye